also my opponents might be crying oval
opponents here okay um what'd you do
play d4 by a three you six its
opponent's gonna play hippo probably
let's try and destroy the hippo hmm play
Knight d2 maybe the Queen belong done D
- well that's okay the knight will
maneuver I want to play this this if
I've included
yeah I'm gonna have like all my pieces
directed at the Kings side this pawns
pins I'm gonna play c3 first just for
good measure
Bishop c2 expecting b5 or that move that
moves a better or that moves a worse
move I should say opponent wants to take
back yeah sometimes in life you can't
undo your mistakes just have to live
with them and get fourths okay I'm up a
queen and a rook my knight is doing
damage threading a pawn geez Bates
welcome back
yeah so I'll be playing the a Grenadier
arena
no a lot of people and messaging me
asking hopefully the thing in the chats
answers the question rofl axis that's
the best sort of right hearts is in
rosin face I could fork I could move in
for the kill
yeah I think I'll go for the kill the G
palm do of botas gambits
well my opponent already did a boat s
cannons I can do a counter boat as
gambit but I think one one boat says
gambit is enough at least for one game
ball gamma the pawn more like trail upon
the goal is to Castle King side with
checkmate not sure if that will be
feasible
but I guess I have to just believe in
myself already calculating like take
stakes here here King will take I still
have to control this square somehow and
the square a lot of squares to control
so maybe my rook will come in a little
zig zag the way to destiny okay let's
take a bishop whoa
the first bits of the stream I didn't
even see that comment before I said what
I said but at this point I know tog II
so well I can predict what the bit
message will be how do I meet let's play
this move
this move oh it's so close
hello my Castle kingside with meats I
mean I have made in one but that's not
as fun hmm
[Music]
castling kingside with meat is actually
a challenge because I need to get the
king to a file but I'm controlling all
these squares so I have to play some
dumb Knight move oh I see it I see it
it's gonna be I'm threatening me than
two yeah look at this castling kingside
with mates I did it oh I should just
retire from chess and take up another
hobby oh that's so beautiful it's been a
while since I've Castle kingside
or castles at all with checkmate it's
very ironic because I get I get my king
safe while destroying the opponent's
king true definition of multipurpose
thanks for the game don't cry BAE don't
cry I know it was a brutal finish but to
learn from your mistakes okay that might
go on YouTube because it just ended so
beautifully castling with mates I was
about to say I'll finally have a video
where I don't mention boat s gambit but
I think it was mentioned at some points
anyway for YouTube people watching in
the future thanks for watching you can
like you can subscribe comments you can
share it on reddit and I'll see you in
the future